I was raised Christian depart from
ald the faith IM that she has it is
mindblowing defend against a rapid
spread of microplasma pneumonia AKA
white lung disease using black resins
cogit packed with immune boosting
properties cogit has been scientifically
proven to promote respiratory Health
aiding in oxygen absorption while also
making the body infection resistant
strengthen your family's immune system
ahead of the new outbreak this winter
don't forget to use my discount code Ali
dawa for 15% off
enjoy brothers and sisters and dear
friends in I came across this video I
found it so profound and amazing yeah
and I was like you know what I want the
Iman like the level of Iman this woman
has if you was to S and see her if I was
see in a supermarket I would never in a
million years think she's at that level
I don't know how long she's been a
Muslim yeah but but you can see clearly
that she doesn't look like a Muslim not
that a Muslim look a specific way yeah
but she doesn't wear the hijab but look
at how she deals with this Christian
Missionary you will be shocked I was my
jaw dropped and then we're going to come
to the Quran inah Bak a couple of verses
and learn some key lessons brother and
sisters look and I'm going to tell you
something about your parents your mother
and your father and how it's going to
relate to this let's watch the video for
ourself inshah and then we're going to
come uh react to
it I believe in Jesus but I don't
believe in Jesus is the god or the Lord
Jesus says that I am the way the truth
and the life no one comes to the father
but by means he's the only way to the
father that's the Bible Islam came
centuries later there was no
Christianity no Judaism no anything in
Abraham May a Lov be pleased with him
when he came here what he believed in
was one Creator one God he was
considered a Muslim are you to think of
the two sons of Abraham so you have
Isaac and ishma Isaac was the son of the
promise through Sarah she was very old
and God opened up her womb ishma was the
son of the flesh it was through the maid
Islam is a descended from Ishmael
Christianity is a descendant from Isaac
who was the son of the promise so all
the way back to Abraham remember he had
the son of the promise in Genesis it was
Isaac it was Abraham and Sarah they were
very old and God opened up her womb it
was it was a miracle but Abraham also
had a relation with the young maid and
they had birth a natural way which was
Ish Islam comes from ishma Christianity
comes from Isaac Isaac was the son of
Promise ish was the son of the flesh so
the eyewitnesses of Jesus saw him
crucified for our sins and the Quran
comes centuries later and says that he
only appeared to be crucified now who
are you going to believe eyewitnesses
who lived at the time of Jesus or a book
that comes centuries later called the
Quran that said he appeared the Bible
was written by man people who wrote
about Jesus were not even with es
Matthew was and John was they were both
disciples and Mark got his information
from Peter who was a disciple and I was
raised Christian it's sad that you the
part
Al Jesus said before Abraham was I am
that's what he said from his own words
so before Abraham was he is he is
eternal Quran talks about Jesus but the
Bible never talks about Muhammad it does
ammad Jesus says follow the one that
will come after me that will be The
Peacemaker his name will be ammad can
you tell me where he says that CH no I
can't tell you from now Jesus was
crucified for our sins Buri and he rose
from on the third day he was witnessed
to die and Rise Again by eye witnesses
the Quran comes centuries later and says
that Jesus only appeared to be crucified
so who are you going to believe
eyewitnesses believe the or or a book
that came centuries later that never saw
Jesus but I can't what a man wrote down
over what God revealed Bible is a
revelation from God about pet wrote it
down prophets wrote it down John wrote
it Peter wrote it you have the prophets
so Peter John and the prophets and more
wrote the Bible saying on the third day
it's a revelation from God I no I can't
believe that I promise you that he is
the Son of God and he is the only you
just
took I can't touch you okay let me tell
you something isn't that amazing and
profound yeah you see sometimes you know
like your parents yeah elderly like you
see like you know uh Somali uncles and
aunties or Pakistani uncles and aunties
or Bangladeshi whatever from any
background yeah you go to and say yeah
there's some mistakes in the Quran or
scientific Miracle or this that they say
get the hell out of my face man they
they are not wav it doesn't like Allah
this shows you guidance is from Allah
subhana wa tala Allah guides whom he
wills and misguides whom he wills and
those who are misguided Allah says it is
those who transgress Allah does not
guide the transgressors they did it to
themselves so you see our elders they do
not care W the IM is so strong you can
come with all your rubbish and this
there's a mistake here and this
scientific this Etc made up stuff
whatever it is for that matter it means
nothing for them they're like get out of
here they
say this shows you it is by Allah not
this knowledge that knowledge I know
this no when Allah opens the heart W
this is what counts look at her she is
so strong she's saying Allah
alhamdulillah the guy wants to shake
hands she said no I don't I don't shake
the hand the faith IM that she has it is
mindblowing and that guy is coming with
absolute lies about oh Mark mph Luke who
the hell is Mark mph Luke and John and
Peter who are these people you have zero
evidence to who they are biography who
are these people go and read the new
jum's commentary of the Bible you don't
even know who the hell John is is it
John the seed John the priter or John
the Apostle who is it who are these
people Mark Matthew Luke none of them we
know and then he comes and says to our
sister oh but the Quran came how many
years later how many years later how
many thousand years later did the New
Testament come um and before the Old
Testament so should the Jews now the
Jews reject you guys which is outright
they reject you guys so does that mean
now your um it makes your argument false
yes it does because your claim is if the
Quran came 600 years later that makes
Islam false well then it makes it makes
the New Testament false and Christianity
false because it came thousands years
later after the Old Testament in Moses
what a stupid silly argument so brothers
and sisters not only that that sister
said something very clear our Auntie
yeah and that's true like the prophet in
in the Bible yes it was said and he and
he and Jesus said I have many things to
say unto you but you cannot bear them
now for he when the spirit of truth
shall come he shall guide you onto all
truth he shall not speak of himself as
he hears he shall speak and he shall um
glorify me glorify me look look look
these things who is this the Holy Spirit
which denomination did the Holy Spirit
come to and you know what's very
profound it says he will glorify me
let's put all religions to a side show
us one religion that glorifies Jesus and
believes in his believes in his
miraculous births and the Miracles that
he done with the permission of God
except Islam Islam and the prophet
Muhammad is the only one that fulfills
this by saying and he shall glorify me
amongst other stuff he will not speak of
himself so brothers and sisters W when I
saw this video guidance is from Allah
subhana wa tala and there's a verse in
the Quran Allah says
in
what does Allah subhana wa tala say okay
so Allah says this is a book there is no
doubt about it a guide for the for those
who are mindful of Allah subhana wa tala
yeah who believe believe in the Unseen
establish the prayer and donate from
what we have provided for
them and who believe in what has been
revealed to you or prophet and what was
revealed before you have and have sure
faith in the Hereafter
yes and it is they who are truly Guided
by their lord and it is they who are
successful
yes and lastly as for those who persist
in disbelief it is the same for them
whether you warn them or they not they
will not believe the person on the other
side holding the camera this verse last
verse fits you and the other verses fits
our sister our Auntie may Allah bless
and preserve you like Allah says in the
Quan Bak in other verse in chapter 18 or
15 deaf dumb and blind and they will not
be guided that's all I want to say sh
say share this video with your friends
and family alhamdulillah this lights up
my day alhamd guidance comes from Allah
not what you memorize what you text what
you what you know what memorize text you
memorize it's from Allah may Allah bless
this auntie she lit up our day may Allah
light up our day we don't know who she
is if she doesn't know how to pray Salah
salah.com go and order your guided pray
mat and learn how to pray Salah and we
have onetoone instructors our sister if
we can get in contact with this sister
please please let me know till next time
asalam
Al